das hier bin ich schön oder wie ihr seht
würden diese mistkerle von
weisheitszähnen direkt in die anderen
reinwachsen und alles verschieben
deshalb kommen sie alle vier auf einmal
raus das passiert entweder nur mit
lokaler betäubung wo man keine schmerzen
hat aber trotzdem alles mitkriegt mit
lokaler betäubung und lachgas ja
wirklich wo man keine schmerzen hat aber
alles mitkriegt aber komplett heißt oder
meistens in schlimmeren fällen unter
vollnarkose wo man komplett lahm gelegt
wird und irgendwann hoffentlich wieder
aufwacht ich nehme euch mit denen ist es
wunderbar spaßige abenteuer und
berichtet wie sich die vollnarkose für
mich anfühlt und auf mich aus wirkt aber
auch wie sich tag für tag mein aussehen
verändern wird und ob das wirklich so
schlimm ist hier immer alle sagen
dieses video wird unterstützt von
skilled er ja schon ein bisschen schiss
vor der op was eigentlich kommen ja
quatsch ist weil das voll die routine op
die machen das gefühl jeden tag
ich schaue mir jetzt mal ein video an
wasser genau gemacht wird vielleicht
nicht mehr dass hier ein bisschen die
angst zur vorbereitung zu viel hat das
ganze schon mal letztes jahr
durchgemacht also konnte sie mir
wertvolle tipps geben ich habe also
haufenweise gepäcks organisiert labello
damit meine mundwinkel geschmeidig sind
und bei der op nicht einreißen und
weiche nahrung geklärt dafür habe ich
mir jetzt liebe geholt dann legal spies
mich von meiner nicht essen weil 8 und
meine henkersmahlzeit 500 gramm
ich liebe glauben und morgen kann ich
muss mir essen deswegen ziehe ich mit
ihr zu sein
an diesem tag vor der op hat mich auf
meiner kurse arzt also der anästhesist
angerufen so eine vollnarkose darf
nämlich nicht einfach und jeder
durchführen sondern nur der anästhesist
der typ der mich damit folgen sollte war
echt cool drauf und hab mir dann gesagt
ich soll nicht drin sein das heißt ich
darf eine gewisse zeit vor der klinik
essen und trinken um einzuschlafen
bekommen arkose mittel direkt durch die
vene rein
die narkose hals dann so lange wie
dieses mittel quasi in die venen rhein
fließt und wenn es aufhört dann dauert
circa zehn minuten bis der körper die
chemikalie abgebaut hat und man aufwacht
wir haben das überhaupt rausgefunden und
woher wussten die das was sicher ist und
so ging es dann weiter
nicht ganz so zugesetzt dass ich das
machen wir
und dann ruft die frau an der rezeption
meinen namen auf das ganze team war
super cool driver war ich aufgeregt war
ich bekomme also nun hier einen
intravenösen zugang gelegt durch den
isotonische kochsalzlösung durchfließt
als trägerflüssigkeit für das
narkosemittel das danach erst dazu
geschalten wird der arzt hat mich dann
schon vorgewarnt das ist jetzt ein
bisschen kalt werden könnte und ja also
die flüssigkeit ist halt bei
raumtemperatur deutlich kälter als meine
eigene körpertemperatur mit 37 grad als
hat sich wirklich an geführt also wird
eiskalte flüssigkeit sich langsam aber
sicher durch seine adern hier komplett
nach oben schlängeln in den oberarm rein
komplett in einer bewusst und sie
einfach ausbreiten und das war ja auch
genau das was passiert ist und hier am
handrücken wo die nadel des zugangs eben
rein ging hat auch ein bisschen gebrannt
das zwar normal aber ich habe da
wirklich ein bisschen schiss davor weil
ich ja danach gleich komplett den
kontrollverlust erleben werde der
anästhesist übrigens die ganze zeit mit
mir geredet hat was echt super geholfen
hat als dann langsam der narkose hahn
aufgedreht wodurch nicht viel ruhiger
geworden bin direkt zu dem zeitpunkt
haben dann immer noch gequatscht und er
meinte dann schon okay wir jetzt hier so
richtig gas gibt dann ist es aber auch
gleich vorbei und er redet jetzt einmal
die ganze zeit weiter so als ob er nicht
wüsste dass ich gleich absolut nicht
mehr ansprechbar bin und drehte weiter
auf ich merke schon okay das war's jetzt
nach ihm auch schon die ganze zeit okay
also ich stelle ich bin gleich weg ich
bin gleich weg und der rede dann wollen
wir weiter und dann den mann
man merkt auch richtig wir haben die
kontrolle wie sand durch die finger
rinnt da hast du am 8
häusler ist es vorbei diese
einschlafphase die hat für mich nichts
mit schlafen zu tun ich war bei vollem
bewusstsein und habe hellwach gemerkt
wie ich jetzt langsam wegdreht beim
normalen schlaf ist das wenn es bei mir
so dass ich erst gern einschlafen kann
wenn ich komplett loslassen würde ich
dabei versuchen diesen prozess mit
meinem verstand richtig zu beobachten
könnte ich gar nicht einschlafen das ist
eine ziemlich krasse erfahrung die man
eigentlich sonst nie gekriegt wann kann
man schon mal so richtig bei vollem
bewusstsein sehen wie man jetzt
abdriftet erst jetzt betritt dann der
zahnarzt die bühne während der
anästhesist natürlich permanent mein
puls und meinen narkose zustand
überprüft wie sich der zustand der kurse
für mich angefühlt hat unglaublich was
von der op mitgekriegt hat das käme
gleich jetzt übernimmt der zahnarzt weil
der wahl bei der op definitiv aufmerksam
als ich nach in der thomas durcheinander
touristen betäubt worden ist haben wir
turnier ist oberflächlich betäubt und in
lokalanästhesie durchgeführt und dann im
anschluss die vier weisheitszähne
entfernt klasse war es erforderlich dass
wir ausreichend platz verhältnisse
schaffen und die wurzeln einzelnen
teilen die wurzeln konnten erfolgreich
entfernt werden also vollnarkosen sind
drei was jetzt an ferne möglich und auch
empfehlenswert immer dann wenn im
vorfeld ersichtlich ist dass der
eingriff nicht ganz einfach darstellbar
ist man spricht von europäischen 45
minuten bis eine stunde 15
bei der op zugegen waren der narkose
arzt das op-team was aus meiner person
gestanden ist meinen kollegen und aus
zwei weiteren helferinnen so das
finanzamt zu fünf aufgetreten sind wie
ich dann direkt nach dieser mega
komplizierten op aussah zeigt euch
direkt aber wie war das erlebnis der op
jetzt aus meiner sicht wie fühlt sich
freuen der kurse an
naja also gar nicht der schlafzustand
wenn man ihn so nennen möchte der war
für mich überhaupt nicht geschlafen ich
hab da so wie die meisten anderen
übrigens auch nicht geträumt ich habe
davon nichts gespürt nichts gefühlt
nichts gerochen links gehört gar nichts
was natürlich auch dass in der sache ist
wenn das hier die zeit ist und das quasi
mein level an bewusstsein
dann war das bewusstsein natürlich
erstmal ganz normal als narkosearzt dann
so langsam gas gegeben hat ging es
natürlich so langsam nach unten
also dann so richtig gas gegeben hat
dagegen fährt immer schneller bis ganz
unten wo es ein komplett weg war das
natürlich spekulation aber ich gehe
davon aus dass sich dieser zustand hier
genau und wo man einfach gar nichts
gespürt dass ich genauso auch der
zustand des todes 1 anfühlen muss
nämlich nicht genauso wie man vor seiner
geburt auch nichts wahrgenommen hat und
nichts gefunden hat weil man nicht da
war genau soll ich mich gefühlt als
würde ich niemals existieren wenn mich
jetzt während der narkose jemand getötet
hätte dann hätte ich nichts davon
mitgekriegt und ich will einfach für
immer weg mein körper war während der op
natürlich noch da aber ich also das was
mich wirklich ausmacht also mein
bewusstsein
das hat da einfach nicht existiert der
aufwachprozess laden so aus dass ich
natürlich irgendwann mal wach wurde aber
dann langsam wieder eingenickt bin bis
ich dann am ende so halbwegs bewusstsein
aufgestanden bin und hat ein bisschen
gedauert bis ich wieder auf dem dampfer
war wie das jetzt in der realität aussah
das sehen wir jetzt
[Musik]
sind und welche weil
ach ja dieses super gruselige dinge auf
meinem gesicht ist basically eine
wasserkühlung fürs gesicht durch die
ständig kaltes wasser gepumpt wird was
echt viel krasser ist als kühl pads
teure wagen braucht es winter so bin ich
auch machen so eine kleine kammer
trainer war so dürfen
weil da rein
zu haben aber das war uns einfach am
besten
[Musik]
er ist im ziel naja gehöre die be-
reinalter weil das denke ich schon
gelesen meinen donnern ich fast haus
meine werke mich immer gleich eine rolle
die zunge andere zunge ausgetauscht ja
das stimmt
noch komplett ohne vogel nicht
[Musik]
eigentlich die nächsten zwei tage noch
voller kursen sollen
ich glaube das ist auch nicht so gewohnt
aber wie ging es danach weiter also ich
hab mir eigentlich vorgenommen das ganze
ding mit videos zu dokumentieren wie es
mir geht wie ich reden kann wie ich esse
aber nötig war den nächsten vier bis
fünf tage komplett ko ich habe mir auch
vorgenommen nach zwei tagen kannst
mitarbeiten bei vielen leuten ist
versucht oder das ist geht aber ich war
also vier tage wirklich komplett außer
gefecht und konnte nichts machen habe
mich einfach nur ein geschüttet
schmerzmittel genommen mich gekühlt und
world of warcraft gespielt und nicht nur
meine schmerzen betäubt sondern damit
auch mein geist drückt so sah ich dann
am tag der op aus da habe ich nur um
gelegen und vor mich hin vegetiert meine
backen sondern zu dem zeitpunkt noch
nicht richtig angespannt ich war an
diesem tag direkt nach der op wirklich
komplett hilflos ich konnte ich allein
trinken essen gar nichts halte mich
sebastian nicht von der op direkt
abgeholt und hätte sich meine freundin
nicht so wurde mich gekümmert ich weiß
nicht ob ich das gemacht habe weil ich
war echt wirklich zu nichts zu
gebrauchen tag 2 wurde dann von den
schmerzen wenn ich viel besser
man sieht lang sind die bäckchen tat
zwar eigentlich genauso gut wie die tag
3 da sage ich dann so aus wurde das
päckchen dann noch besser am vierten tag
sehe ich dann immer noch so aus als
hätte ich 50 kilo zugenommen
der fünfte tag war dann so man sieht das
immer noch meine lippe extrem
aufgerissen ist ihr müsst euch das
vorstellen ich hatte echt kleinen mund
und die zahnärzte die mussten ja richtig
weit nach hinten um richtig komplizierte
sachen dazu machen und dabei ist es
wirklich aufgerissen das kann mal
passieren und die eingerissenen lippen
die dann auch gealtert haben die waren
wirklich das schlimmste erst an tag 6
sah ich dann wieder halbwegs normal aus
und auch da kam so langsam der
lebenswille auch ruhig da zurück dass
man ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen die die
ersten vier fünf tage also lange hätte
ich das nicht mitgemacht wirklich nicht
und hier an tag 7 nach einer woche und
sehe ich eigentlich halbwegs normal
wieder aus man sich noch ein bisschen
dass die backe angeschwollen ist aber
auch zu diesem zeitpunkt kann ich meinen
mund noch nicht mehr als einen
zentimeter öffnen und auch jetzt
elf tage nach der op sieht dass wenn ich
mein mund weiter öffne so aus es wird
immer besser und es wird sich auch lägen
aber aktuell ich kann auch nicht in den
bürgern weißen oder so ich kann auch
nicht in den apfelwein weißen aber nur
pizza die konnte ich heute schon essen
was das bei mir jetzt ein bisschen
komplizierter gemacht hat ist das meine
zahnwurzeln direkt in den lippen der
freien gehen den ihr hier jetzt mal so
leicht rot eingezeichnet und das heißt
und das hat mir auch der zahn uns gesagt
dass wenn da irgendwas schiefgeht könnte
es sein dass die lippen nerv durchtrennt
wird und ich meine lippe nicht mehr
bewegen kann und nicht mehr spüren kann
und deswegen mussten die halt umso
vorsichtiger sein
ich musste jeden tag drei antibiotika
nehmen habe jeden tag drei bis vier
ibuprofen 800 gramm genommen und
zusätzlich drei mal am tag noch ein
anderes schmerzmittel in tröpfchen form
aber jetzt ist wieder einigermassen
alles okay ich kann ja ganz normal reden
ich kann auch wieder lachen ich kann
auch wieder festzubeißen ich kann nur
mein mund noch nicht weit aufbringen und
das muss ich trainieren und vielleicht
ist es ja noch mal einer woche wieder
ganz normal an dieser stelle nochmal
danke anne sophie die sich jetzt so gut
um mich gekümmert hat und auch schon
tipps von ihrer op für mich hatte die
echt extrem wichtig waren auch dank
einer guten sebastian euro abgeholt hat
aber auch an die zahnarztpraxis an
kultur hier in köln erste super gemacht
meine große leidenschaft ist das coole
dinge zu lernen und jede woche ein neues
projekt anzugehen ist gilt er hat
unzählige klassen in denen man so gut
wie alles lernen kann wie zum beispiel
produktivität selbstständigkeit film
oder fotografie und das nicht nur als
anfänger sondern auch als profi momentan
bringe ich mir mit dem kurs produktive
team aster klar ist principles and tools
zur boost your productivity meine
effizienz auf das nächste level in der
klasse wird gezeigt wie man mit der
formel für produktivität kontrolle für
sich selbst erlangt um die dinge zu tun
die einen wirklich weiterbringen erst
noch 500 meine abonnenten bekommen über
den link in der beschreibung zwei proben
monate der premium-mitgliedschaft das
gilt ja hat keine störende werbung es
kommen permanent neue klassen dazu mit
denen man sich weiterentwickeln kann und
skater kostet mit einem jährlichen abo
nur acht euro im monat also schlag zu
wenn er mich auf dieser reise begleiten
möchte und schon vor den videos immer
kleine ausschnitte aus den experimenten
sehen möchtet dann folgen gerne mal auf
installieren da gibt es in den stores
vor allem wenn man schon davor was zu
sehen und abonniert diesen kanal und
dann sehen wir zunächst mal wieder
macht's gut
[Musik]